ja die teilnehmer von flugangst haben
sich ziemlich eindeutig entschieden sie
wollen eine sondersendung zum thema wie
man philosophische hausarbeiten verfasst
wir haben schon ein paar sendungen dazu
gemacht oben rechts machen wir jetzt im
folgenden links dazu rein aber
vielleicht kann man das noch einmal ganz
klar und deutlich ganz komprimiert
zusammenfassen auf was es mir und auch
anderen dozierenden ankommt also ganz zu
beginn sollte man sagen dass nicht jedes
interessante thema gleichermaßen für
eine philosophische hausarbeit geeignet
ist ein fehler in meinen augen der
häufig auftritt bei studierenden gerade
auch zu beginn des studiums ist der dass
ein thema besonders wichtig erscheint
besonders eingängig erscheint aber dass
ich dann bei näherer betrachtung
herausstellt dass es eigentlich gar
nicht richtig zu begreifen es ist es
vielleicht auf den ersten blick nur
interessant aber bei näherer betrachtung
ist es zu konfus oder und nicht ganz
klar also nicht jedes interessante thema
ist gleichermaßen geeignet um das
philosophisch zu behandeln viele themen
sind genauer gesagt für einen
philosophischen hausarbeit oder auch für
eine anlage bei zu weit man kommt von
hölzchen aufs stöckchen und man hat
keine priorisierung der fragen und es
bringt mich zum nächsten punkt zur frage
wie man ein geeignetes thema für eine
hausarbeit findet das ist die frage die
ganz am anfang stehen muss ganz
allgemein kann man sagen dass ein thema
ein geeignetes thema für eine
philosophische hause war klar umrissen
und systematisch interessant sein sollte
was es mit dem systematisch
interessanten auf sich hat werde ich
gleich noch genauer erklären
es sollte sich aus leitfragen motivieren
lassen also interessantes thema das
geeignet ist von hausarbeit das lässt
sich in leitfragen re formulieren und
motivieren es lässt sich durch leid
probleme genauer beschreiben oder auch
nur durch ein problem also ein
interessantes thema ist ein
interessant ist problem eine
interessante frage die man beantworten
kann aber die etwas zeit und raum
braucht und vor allem die gute argumente
benötigt und das ist das worauf es hier
ankommt auf die argumentation also
philosophieren bedeutet nicht so sehr
antworten parat zu haben sondern gute
und treffende fragen aufzuwerfen und
probleme als interessante probleme
überhaupt erst zu erkennen
man kann sagen es gibt mehr oder weniger
interessante probleme und gute
philosophinnen und gute philosophen die
schaffen es die interessanten die
wirklich wichtigen oder wirklich
thematisieren probleme von weniger
wichtigen oder zu unklaren problem zu
unterscheiden
damit hängt zusammen eine philosophische
hausarbeit sollte einen klaren fokus
haben wohl nicht abschweifen das hängt
natürlich ganz klar mit dem thema
zusammen passt man sich vor setzt ein
ungeeignetes thema wird nicht erlauben
einen klaren fokus zu setzen
das wird dazu führen dass man abschweift
und ich würde immer empfehlen wenn man
jetzt eine interessante frage gefunden
hat die sich wirklich auch im rahmen
einer hausarbeit auf zehn bis zu maximal
20 seiten angemessen behandeln lässt
hier erstmal sich eigenständige gedanken
zu machen bevor man gleich auf die
sekundärliteratur übergeht der grund
dafür ist folgender wenn ich gleich in
die sekundärliteratur übergeht dann
werde ich schon möglich antworten und
argumente geliefert bekommen ohne mir
meine eigenen gedanken dazu machen zu
können und philosophieren heißt ja
selbst denken
das heißt erst mal wenn man schon mal
selbst die leitfrage gewählt hat sich
eigene mögliche antworten und argumente
über liegen die zur beantwortung dieser
leitfrage beitragen können und ihre es
dann in die sekundärliteratur übergehen
und auch nur so über gehen dass man die
thesen der sekundärliteratur nicht
nimmt sondern immer vor dem hintergrund
der eigenen erkenntnisse argumente
überprüft und bewertet und integriert
diskutiert ja die ausarbeitung einer
philosophischen hausarbeit besteht dann
in der entfaltung einer argumentation
das heißt ein problem wenn man es
philosophisch behandelt und versucht zu
lösen
das löst man nicht auf einen schlag sind
das braucht gewisse schritte bis zur
lösung und diese schritte der
argumentation die zur lösung dieser
frage zur beantwortung dieser frage zur
lösung dieses problems führen
die geben dann die gliederung der arbeit
vor zb indem man verschiedene teil
probleme analysiert insgesamt sollte
dann betrachtet die hausarbeit einen
roten faden erkennen lassen also sollte
jeder schritt aus dem vorherigen eine
gewisse folgerichtigkeit folgen und die
arbeit sollte in sich stimmig sein
sollte abgestimmt sein also ein teil
kommt auf den nächsten folgt auf den
nächsten weil er die logische konsequenz
des vorherigen teils ist und man kann
auch sagen dass eine hause bei unser
besser ist je tiefer und differenzierter
sie zur beantwortung der leitfrage
beiträgt weniger ist mehr
gewissermaßen also bin ich nicht mehr
bringen mehr argumente mehr reflexion
ihrer konzentration vertiefung das ist
immer wichtiger ja das war es von meiner
seite anregungen weitere fragen könnt
gerne im kommentarbereich unter diesem
video eingebracht werden